die fragenlotterie mit mono neuverschuldung
und eine ganz wichtige frage ist sein
vater für seinen erfolg verantwortlich schau
und sehe alles fragwürdige okay also wir haben
sehr schöne fragen für dich wie eine grüne
ich kann keine fiesen fragen für
dich haben das ist eine rote  du kannst
dich erschießen ich nehme die fiesen ok
das und das ist das so rolle
ich ich bin gefährlich ja du musst
befehlen es zu drehen okay du musst es reißen okay
ja alles klar lass uns sehen was du hast
als wir jung waren
hast du vor dem spiegel mit einer
haarbürste gesungen du willst, dass es ein star wird ist
dein traum wahr geworden das ist toll das ist
ziemlich interessant denn ich denke eines
der dinge die ich ständig wiederhole war
ich  nie eines dieser Kinder, oh nein, ich
kann es nicht glauben, ich war ein kleiner
Performer, aber ja, ja, weil ich
früher den Staat gespielt habe, weißt du, ich spiele immer noch,
ja, Israel Jump, und ich habe immer versucht
, bei jedem von uns das Rampenlicht zu stehlen
Konzerte ja und ich hatte viel ha  Irgendwann hatte
ich so einen großen Haartag und
ja, ich denke, es ist, weißt du, ich glaube,
es gibt einen kleinen Teil in uns allen, der
das Rampenlicht mag, ja, weißt du,
vor 15.000 Leuten auf die Bühne zu gehen,
ich meine, es ist ein unbeschreibliches
Gefühl  Ja, was ist das
Gefühl, ist es, was es beschreibt, es ist
wie Sex oder wie, ja, es ist anders, weißt du
, ich meine, Sex ist so eine Art
intime Erfahrung, ist so eine
geschlossene Erfahrung, weißt du, mit dem
Leben von etwas fühlt sich einfach so gut an
von global, so eine Art
Masse, die Sie kennen, fast sozialistisch in Bezug auf die Anzahl der
beteiligten Personen, und es gibt kein
anderes Medium, in dem Sie so viele Menschen haben,
die in die gleiche Richtung zeigen
und Energie lenken, die Sie kennen, besonders wenn
es sich um einen positiven Song handelt, der so
viel Energie lenkt  in einem Spieler ist eine sehr,
sehr starke Sache, und ich denke, wie
viele Darsteller, bin ich sehr, sehr
demütig darüber, Sie wissen, was ich meine, ich komme von der
Bühne und ich meine, ich rede jetzt einfach darüber,
ich kann  Ich fühle es, du weißt, dass du diese Energie fühlst,
ja, aber ja, es ist mächtig. Ich meine,
ich hatte, ich hatte ein paar, weißt du,
manchmal hast du einen harten Auftritt, weil es
sich nicht wirklich richtig anhört, und du
gibst immer noch eine gute Leistung  Show, aber du musst dich sehr
konzentrieren und manchmal
schwebst du weg, weißt du, und du bist in einer
anderen Zone, es fühlt sich fast so an, als gäbe
es keine Bühne und kein Publikum, es ist nur eine
Sache, eine Sache, und du weißt, ich will es
haben  Ich hatte die Gelegenheit,
das in meinem Leben zu tun, du weißt, es ist nur
etwas, das ich nie vergessen würde, okay, also
mag ich diese fiesen Fragen
zu antworten, es gibt eine nette
ja ja ja weil das ist in ordnung
weil sie sagen wow warum bist du so
talentiert was du siehst siehst du dass das
lässt dich erst einmal wissen davon ausgehen
dass ich denke dass ich talentiert bin ja
das ist die schwierigkeit ich  Ich
denke, ich denke ehrlich, dass ich ein bisschen Talent hatte,
und Sie wissen, dass ich es habe  Okay, ich bin
mit einer Stimme gesegnet worden, um tun zu können, was
ich tue, aber das ist ein kleiner Teil davon, der
Rest war nur hartnäckige Entschlossenheit,
harte Arbeit, eine Art Weigerung,
einen Traum loszulassen. Ich bin sehr, sehr stur  Ich bin ein
Steinbock, also war für mich die Tatsache sehr,
sehr beruhigend, dass, wenn ich
an etwas arbeite, fast bis ich an meinem
Punkt des Wahnsinns bin, die Chancen gut stehen, dass es
gelingt, wissen Sie,
deshalb würde ich sagen, so so so  Ja, Talent,
aber eines meiner Talente ist, dass ich kann. Ich
kann ziemlich viel härter arbeiten als
jeder andere. Übrigens, Hi-Wedge-Spiele erzählen
davon. Es ist ein seltsamer Vincent. Es
gibt überall Musik
die Fähigkeit, hart zu arbeiten,
komme aus der Stadt,
all das, das ganze Bild. Ich denke, es ist
ein bisschen Jeans, es hat viel
mit meiner Umgebung zu tun. Weißt du, ich hatte
sehr kreative Eltern, meine Mutter,
besonders tolle Platten im Haus
Ermutigen Sie uns immer, kreativ zu sein,
um uns auszudrücken  Weißt du,
Musik zu machen war für mich keine Rebellion,
weil mir das Gefühl gegeben wurde, es wäre
mein Recht, weißt du, das war riesig
Teil davon okay, also ja, es ist schlecht, wir
haben das Recht, ich denke, das sind alles böse
Fragen, ähm nein, das ist nicht wirklich da,
okay, lass uns eine andere böse Frage stellen, okay,
du weißt, was das ist, deshalb
kicherst du, du bist Single  New Age
war acht Wochen lang auf Platz eins der deutschen Charts,
aber die Leute fragen immer noch,
wer Marlon Roudette ist, ist es nicht schade, dass ich
fertig bin, nein, nein, wenn ich
in der Rush Hour durch Deutschland laufe und niemand
mich erkennt, glaube ich  Ich denke, es ist
verständlich, dass
es eine Weile dauert,
bis die Leute den Namen mit dem
Gesicht des Songs in Verbindung bringen, wenn sie von der Band zu einem neuen Namen wechseln
Glaube an
das Album, wir sind nicht verzweifelt, du weißt,
wir wissen, dass wir Zeit haben  ins
Bewusstsein der Menschen zu rücken und ich habe
viel Energie dafür, denn am Ende
des Tages bin ich einfach ich selbst, es ist nicht
so, dass ich diese Show oder
diesen Act aufführen muss, das kommt ganz
leicht  diese Seite der Dinge, aber ja, es ist
etwas, woran wir hart arbeiten,
Regina, aber vielleicht ist es auf diese
Weise besser, dass nicht so viele Leute
dein Gesicht kennen, und oh, das ist mein Lon, der tot war,
ja, ich will von dir, ja, ja, genau
das ist nicht  so eine schlimme sache okay ich
will dir meinen namen auf den arm tätowieren okay
ja wir haben uns getroffen effekt ist doch heute passiert
ja heute musste ich ein autogramm für
einen fan machen denn morgen hat sie einen
termin mit dem tätowierer und
er wird mir ein autogramm tätowieren  Auf unserer
Ich meine Verrücktheit so, aber gleichzeitig erstaunlich,
dass einige davon sogar
jemanden berührt haben,
aber ähm, ich denke, es ist sehr, sehr wichtig
für mich, weil ich denke, dass es ein erstaunliches
Album ist und ich möchte, dass die Leute das
Album genießen und es bekommen  Album, weil ich denke,
es ist ein  zeitlose Platte und und um das zu tun
, müssen sie es verstehen und sich darauf
einlassen, einen Künstler zu verwenden, also ist es
etwas, dessen ich mir bewusst bin und ich
arbeite sehr hart daran, und ja, und ihr
Jungs helft, ja, das sollten wir auch
gehen Sie für ein böses oder ja, ich verkoste Sie,
weil es uns gefällt, dass der böse Typ
genug mag, um äh ja und okay zu tun, ja, ich
mag ein bisschen Kontroverse. Mal sehen, seien Sie
ehrlich, Ihr Vater ist
glücklicherweise mit dieser
bösen Frage für Ihren Erfolg verantwortlich  Ich kann ehrlich sagen, dass er
nie in meine Karriere involviert war, das ist
seltsam, denn hier, als ich ein bisschen
über dich gelesen habe, lese ich, dass er einer der
erfolgreichsten Musikproduzenten in London ist.
Nun, ich weiß nicht, ob er
Erfolg hatte, ja, aber und er hat
und er hat mit einigen sehr, sehr
talentierten Leuten gearbeitet und ich bin sehr stolz auf
das, was er erreicht hat, aber Sie wissen, dass
ich mit meiner Mutter in einer Familie mit einem Elternteil aufgewachsen bin
, das war immer die größte
Inspiration für mich und ich erinnere mich, dass ich
dorthin gegangen bin  ins Atelier  meines Vaters und ich
erinnere mich, dass ich
bei einigen Sessions irgendwie zusammengehangen und assistiert habe und ich habe
einige Künstler getroffen, aber in Bezug auf meine
Karriere denke ich, dass es wichtig war, dass
ich losgezogen bin, um mein eigenes Ding zu machen, und vielleicht, wenn
ich das wirklich bin  Ehrlich zu mir selbst, es gibt einen
Punkt zu beweisen, dass es viele verschiedene Dinge geben kann, die Sie
motivieren, und das ist eine Motivation, es
ohne Ihren Vater zu
tun  Unsere
Beziehung war sehr, sehr
schwierig, also denke ich, dass es sowieso keine
Option war, ok, aber ich denke, das
war das Beste, weil Sie wissen, dass ich
wirklich bin, wenn ich mich hinsetze und über
meine Karriere nachdenke, und ich denke an meine
Erfolge und alles  Ich bin sehr,
sehr stolz auf die Art von
Ich habe es nicht gesagt, dass etwas
falsch daran ist, sich auf die Familie zu verlassen, aber
ja, und ich hatte auch immer
den Nachnamen meiner Mutter und weil
sie den größten Einfluss hatte  in ihrem Los
in meinem Leben bin ich  sehr, sehr stolz darauf,
ihren Namen zu tragen, also ja, das ist
wichtig für mich, oder ist es stattdessen
schwierig, eine Karriere als Musiker zu haben
?  in
großbritannien ja ja gut ich habe wegen
des hits in deutschland habe ich jetzt einen großen vertrag
ja nein es ja ich glaube nicht in
großbritannien ist es ihnen egal du weißt es ist
es ist es ist ein hit kannst du live singen  bah
bah bla bla bla der Familienanschluss
ist ein ist ein von dem du weißt, aber du bist
irgendwie verdammt, wenn du verdammt, wenn
du es nicht mit dem berühmten
Familienanschluss machst, denn wenn du es nicht
in einer Pressemitteilung erwähnst oder  Was auch immer eine
Zeitung ein Jahr später herausfindet,
bekommt einen Knüller und plötzlich bist du
ein Betrüger, du weißt, dass du eine Geschichte vom Tellerwäscher zum Millionär gemalt hast,
und es ist nicht wahr,
richtig, aber dann, wenn du es
aufnimmst, fragen dich alle  darüber und sie sagen,
okay, du musst Hilfe gehabt haben,
aber versteh mich nicht falsch  g Familie
im Musikgeschäft und nicht nur mein Vater,
mein Onkel auf der Seite meiner Mutter waren alle
Musiker, mein Cousin war bei Island
Records unter Vertrag  Figur, also war es
in der ganzen Familie richtig, eine Familie zu haben,
die bewiesen hat, dass man
im Musikgeschäft erfolgreich sein kann, ist eine große
Inspiration  Sie
wissen, dass Sie sehr, sehr glücklich waren, das zu haben
, also haben Sie einige Ihrer Familienangehörigen gefragt,
was die Schwierigkeiten sind, was
Ihre Erfahrung war, nein, weil ich es gesehen habe,
Sie haben es gesehen, ja, Sie sehen es aus der Nähe,
Sie sehen, wie es ist, die Presse zu haben
Lügen über dich Du weißt, du weißt,
wie es ist, wenn die Plattenfirma
dich verarscht Du weißt, dass du es aus nächster Nähe gesehen hast, also kennst du
meine
Stiefmutter Naina Tere, du weißt sogar auf
dem Höhepunkt ihres Ruhms, dass sie eine Mutter war
f  Zuerst eine Frau, eine erstaunliche Frau. Zuerst war
sie eine gute Freundin der Menschen, und das war,
was ich sah, das war die größte Wirkung
auf mich. Ich denke, von der Seite meines Vaters
aus der Familie war die Tatsache,
dass sie auf dem Höhepunkt ihres Ruhmes immer
noch war  Der Nano, von dem ich wusste, dass er eine
Stiefmutter ist, und ich habe versucht, das zu akzeptieren.
Ich habe versucht, das voranzubringen. Okay, also
endlich lachen. Ich mag diese
fiesen  augenstern, aber ohne allüren
ich habe ein paar ass und gnaden
weißt du und ich weiß nicht warum ich weiß nicht ich
denke die kombination von gründen schickte
vincent und die grenadinen wahrscheinlich die
größte sehr kleine insel jeder
kennt dich schon vorher  Du bist berühmt,
jeder kennt dich und wenn du nach Hause
gehst, ist es den Leuten egal, was du gemacht hast,
wie berühmt du bist, wie viel Geld du
hast, sie betrachten dich als denselben alten
Jungen, und das ist wirklich sehr wichtig,
die Art von Freunden, die das sind  Ich habe, sie
lassen mich nicht  Wenn man in den Himmel schwebt, gibt es
einen schnellen Schlag nach unten, bevor man sehr
weit kommt, also war das sehr, sehr wichtig. Ich
habe mir selbst ein paar Versprechungen gemacht, bevor
ich in das Geschäft eingestiegen bin. Ich habe sie tatsächlich
aufgeschrieben
war, dass du
die Manieren, die Mum mir beigebracht hat, irgendwie nicht vergessen
solltest. Du kennst die sehr, sehr einfachen Dinge
durchweg, weil du weißt, dass ich denke, du
willst auf deine Karriere zurückblicken und
am Ende des Tages stolz auf dich sein
und so weiter  Das war sehr, sehr wichtig
, dieses Gefühl, das du kennst, und noch einmal von
irgendeinem Vincent, jedes Mal, wenn du aus dem
Haus gehst, achtest du auf deine Ps und Qs, weil die
Chancen gut sind, dass sie deine Mutter kennen, und
wenn du nach Hause kommst, hat sie einen
Anruf bekommen, dass sie es ist  Warten, weißt du, also habe ich mich
irgendwie
weltweit beworben, weißt du, also denke ich, dass das sehr,
sehr wichtig ist, und aber weißt du, ich bin sicher,
dass es Zeiten geben wird, in denen es schwierig ist
und eine Geschichte herauskommt oder was auch
immer, also weißt du, dass es eine ist
Flitterwochen richtig  Jetzt wollen wir sehen, warum
ja, das ist richtig, ja, okay, Weisheit
passiert, ja, genau, vielen Dank,
danke, brillant, tschüss, vielen Dank.
Wenn Ihnen also diese Fragenlotterie mit
Milan Wooded gefällt, wird Ihnen die
Fragenlotterie mit Nickel gefallen, zurück zu der Chet
die Frage beantwortet  Wie wichtig
Geld für ihn ist, sind sie der Grund für diese
Frage und Analyse. Mikoshi ha
Comenzado Smith I Körper, der
Albumpflege nach Tasmanien von YouTube bekommt, hat seine eigene
Opment auf Sean eingelöst
Teil basierte auf Rücken